did you know the song Wild Thoughts by
DJ Khaled samples a children's cartoon
in 1993 Rizzo from mutang sampled Alan
toussaint's cover of the Underdog theme
song by taking three seconds of the
vocals and looping them over and over I
guess Wu-Tang really is for the children
[Music]
iconic Loop became the inspiration for
Wyclef Jean as Santana on their 1999
number one song Maria Maria but instead
of settling vocals they ripped the tar
Melody inspired by the loop
then in 2017 DJ Khaled interpolated the
bass guitar and percussion of Maria
Maria to create an extremely similar
song Wild thoughts featuring Rihanna and
Bryson tiller
[Music]